but you when you asked him about him
traveling to Costa Meson and stuff yes I
also know that can I just also and I
you're single still right mhm yeah I
also know the level he's at I'm sorry
yeah but like I I'm sorry I apologize
but I I may I may I speak my mind and we
can cut it out if you want please all
right but I just have to say that you
and I are playing two different
sports oh what do you mean what kind in
the vag field oh okay they're two
different sports like like you're
playing pickle ball and I'm playing ping
pong what are we
talking slams and he's I'm still in the
pro circuit I'm still in the pro circuit
but I've never been to Wimbleton he's
not on ESPN yet or US Open or that yet
yet yet or he used to be back in the day
he's like D-League pickle ball no no I'm
still no I don't have a D-League it's
not a D-League lady are you in the
D-League you were are you in the D
League oh she's in d d I'm talking
about know what I'm saying is is that I
I know um it's just that you know it's a
different crop of people that he dates I
don't think so I think we've literally
been on dates with the same
people that's I'm being serious I think
there was like L I asked San I was like
yo does this who's this oh yeah Bobby
used to cool but can I say this though
yeah and we're going to cut
right mhm right yes it's somebody that
looks at me and she thinks that I I
really like I'm like a bus boy at PF
Changs like you just like a nothing
nothing well it's not nothing I know but
she she'll see high and stuff but she's
like any thought of even being in a
sexual thing with me would make her
vomit no yeah she said that she said
that not really but maybe that's her
like hitting on you no no I know she's
already no she's we've already talked
about she's like you know what I mean
that's pretty clear it's pretty clear
yeah yeah yeah and she did exact like
that can I see like a woman you've been
on a date with or can you show me the a
photo of the girl you flew out to see
from blank city new foundin new foundin
what do she right now yeah or just a the
last gr one on a date with to they are
all very pretty I've met one or two and
they're all gorgeous women so I don't
know what the [__] he's talking about
and do you shake their hand and lean
into their ear good [__]
luck his rule is no if if I meet them
his rule is like don't talk [__] about
me so like I don't I don't I don't talk
about him like at all well how do you
introduce her or do people just know
they know yeah usually they know yeah
well I mean one one of the girls I I
used to see is somebody that I still
very much like it's just we just live in
different states it's hard like mind
States yeah mental States yeah mental
States yeah she lives two houses down
but mentally mentally she's in can I see
a photo of a girl you want on to date
with cuz I think you undo yourself which
girl who oh well I that was a good can I
just show you a photo of a girl that
I've had sex with sure even better show
me [__] her that'd be cool all I'm
telling you Trevor they're all tens
they're gorgeous yes i' sex with her hot
what do you complain which one is that
like it's a [__] holographic so
pretty are you crazy Bobby blur all that
out no keep it in let him know he's
[__] that's hard but but also but you
have but I've also been in situations
like New Foundland
like well that one that's just [__] on
her part yeah that was a hard one and at
that I'm glad it happened because I'm
like oh I'm going to take a break on
dating in general because it's like I
don't yeah you know although I I am
going to another city oh my God this guy
let's go oh yeah yeah let me talk about
that please please can I talk about that
you said you were sto is it the can I
hold on you bleep this out is it the one
yeah a
God another that's a different that's a
third world country it's so far away a
different that's a connecting flight I
say aard Miss I went to a wedding there
it's a connecting flight it's a weird
airport tell us more show me a photo is
it can I go with you what got you to
what makes you want to go
[__] that's not why that's not why at
all and it's so funny that you guys are
doing this right now it's silly you no
I'm G to say something right now it's
very silly what the room is doing right
now it's like you know back in the day
Paul
Rivier he had his horse right MH right
and he would probably travel a couple of
States on his horsey to get a bit of
side dish you know he had 16 kids
exactly he was [__] I know yeah the
British were coming so was
he this is comedy yeah but I think he
was on the horse that night probably
having sex with a stranger and then his
wife's like Paul PA oh there's a war we
gotta go we gotta go yeah yeah he's just
riing that's exactly how it happened
he's riing yeah so so go ahead ask me
questions so what so what about how did
you meet this girl and did she always
live there yeah were you doing she a
small town in a small state oh they have
phones out there she reminds me
of my so when I grew up I had I grew up
in the Green Valley in Powe mhm and it
was kind of an upscale kind of a place
you know that's where Stoneridge Country
Club is M oh and my my my Elementary
School painted Rock Elementary that's
what it was called painted rock yeah and
you go up this gigantic Hill Martin qu
right and it's like when you go up it's
kind of the hills and it's a green
anyway I lived there and there was one
of my best friends in the whole who I
still talk to her name is Bess Hanley
and Bess Hanley was
um I mean I just loved her personality
but she was like your lifelong Crush
best right I used to have a cross out
when I was a kid yeah yeah and now I see
her I still love seeing her when I
played Carolines used to she her and her
husband should to come and um I love her
so much still to this day and anyway so
this girl from um reminds me of her her
not just her look it's just her whole
energy you know what I mean is just the
way she talks and stuff like that so
it's it's just kind of a reminiscence of
you know I mean something that I loved
in the past you know I mean um is she
she if I saw showed you a photo with her
of her she's cute and very pretty but
you would be like oh I would I I
wouldn't see you you know what I mean
dating somebody like that not that she's
you know she's just she's just a a
hardworking you know girl very like um
Pinterest okay like um Christian
Autumn what yeah yeah um very
um it's um how do you say like she's
pretty wholesome wholesome pretty no no
not edgy okay yeah she's it's like any
of these Christian autumn no yeah yeah
yeah I swear to God chisan if I take
melatonin that's what I see
in that right there kills me yeah I mean
even the the the black girl has the
Christian Autumn thing yeah you know
mean every husband and there is so glad
they're out of the house taking this
photo like than [__] God here's also
what I really liking a woman and I think
it's a it's a quality my mom had sounds
weird no that's very true it's very you
like but the quality that my mom had is
and my dad right big rack no
no they grind it out and they're
hardworking and they don't complain
that's great I love that and so she's
not like you know you know what I'm
going to do only fans or whatever she's
like I just ethically it's not I just
can't do it ethically mhm and my value
system so I'm just going to you know and
and here's what makes it why the reason
why I'm doing it like this is because I
had a famous
comic a month ago I was at the Improv
yeah and this super famous comic who I'm
very good friends with kind of goes hey
how's so and so it was a girl I was
saying in LA